[Musique]
durant 3 jours la Réunion accueille la
49e conférence internationale du réseau
habitat et
francophonie ce sont plus de 80 experts
du logement venant d'une vingtaine de
pays qui sont attendus une conférence
qui a débuté ce lundi 30 mai dans
l'hémicycle du Palais de la
source la 49e conférence du réseau habit
fr onie se déroule cette année à la
réunion nous avons pensé que l'île avait
des choses à montrer en matière
d'habitat nous avons traité les aspects
sociaux du logement il y a 2 ans à haras
l'année dernière nous avons traité les
aspects développement durable changement
climatique à Raba au Maroc et cette
année nous traitons des aspects
économiques du logement donc tout ce qui
est filière de logement tout ce qui est
emploi insertion et nous allons parler
de tout au long de cette journée
au programme de la journée table ronde
séance de travail afin d'échanger de
débattre sur les perspectives du
logement social dans chacun des pays de
la Francophonie pour nous ici à la
Réunion la question du logement pas
uniquement de l'habitat est une
situation préoccupante et l'une des
préoccupations aussi des familles
rayonnaises et pour nous il est
important de pouvoir dresser le les
bases permettre aussi que ces travaux
qui se sont tenus depuis ce matin sur le
loge sur pas uniquement
loger des familles mais surtout comment
et dans quelles conditions ils vont y
être ils vont y habiter et avec bien sûr
le développement durable donc toutes ces
questions été posées ce matin et nous
espérons ben sur les trois journées les
de les deux journées qui restent ben que
le réseau habitat de la Francophonie
puisse dégager des pistes d'action pour
pouvoir améliorer les conditions de ces
famemilles une conférence placée sous
l'égit de Dominique saorin préfet de la
Réunion qui a présenté le livre blanc
pour un aménagement durable du
territoire réunionné le livre blanc les
services de l'État viennent de de
produire et qui est présenté
officiellement cette
semaine c'est une réflexion qui a débuté
il y a maintenant un an et demi pour
définir ce que pourrait être une ville
durable tropicale à la à la Réunion
adaptée au territoire de La Réunion
alors c'est la vision des services de de
l'État qu'on est amené à avoir un
certain nombre je dirais de opposition
notamment en matière égalienne lorsqu'il
s'agit d'instrire des dossiers en
matière d'urbanisme d'urbanisation de
consommation des espaces mais c'est une
aussi une réflexion qui a été amenée qui
a été menée en liaison avec nos
partenaires habituels que sont les
collectivités territoriales que sont les
bailleurs sociaux enfin des associations
diverses et varié de façon à disposer en
quelque sorte d'un référentiel sur ce
que pourrait être l'avenir de
l'aménagement du territoire ici à la
Réunion une rencontre importante et
éminemment stratégique à quelques mois
de la 3e Conférence des Nations Unies
sur le logement et le développement
urbain durable qui se déroulera en
octobre 2016 à Quito en
[Musique]
Équateur